we need someone to take us to an island
located here
that's the deadliest part of the ocean
there is no island there that's my
security system I'd rather take the
Titanic here's the deal a few nights ago
a radio signal got sent out from these
coordinates it could be the mysterious
island that Jules Verne wrote about do
you think you're gonna travel halfway
around the world and meet up with some
lunatic who's messing around on a ham
radio it's not some lunatic it's my
grandfather he's been looking for
mysterious island for over half his life
ladies and gentlemen I give you the
mysterious island
this is heaven I'm checking in
who's up for adventure what is this
place Atlantis two weeks would be on the
cover of Time magazine
let me warn you this island is full of
dark jungles and terrifying creatures
that's emasculating silence about to go
under mm these are rocks eggs they seem
to move carefully lizards have an
incredible sense of smell
I'm blaming you way to slay the hard
getting the attention of a woman is one
of the hardest things to do so you have
got to do this Peck pop of love go on
and throw berry